rights activists are calling for Global
pressure on China this is a photo of the
victim the family of this North Korean
Escape fears a young woman faces
imminent deportation Kim is a mother of
two and was detained last year for
violating coid 19 laws she is among
roughly 2,000 North Koreans believed to
be arrested in China during the pandemic
to be sent back once the borders reopen
a process rights groups say has already
begun Soul has confirmed a large number
of North Koreans were sent back from
three Chinese provinces its unification
Ministry saying it's working to prevent
additional repatriations underlining
that under no circumstances should North
Koreans be sent back against their will
China views these undocumented North
Koreans as illegal economic migrants and
says that its record of deporting
defectors is in line with international
law jimy Young he is one of the success
stories those words forced
repatriation make me numb with
fear words from an escape who twice
endured detention in China before facing
torture in North Korea Freedom with her
two sons came at a high
cost on my third try I resolved to kill
myself if I got caught the torture was
unbearable to this day I can't erase the
trauma it's unknown how many North
Koreans have been forcibly sent back
from China having lived through it g is
pleading with the global Community to
help stop the practice Unis Kim Al jazer
Soul make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer